let's say I have a position vector
function that looks like this R of T is
equal to X of T times the unit vector I
plus y of T times the unit vector J let
me actually graph this so let's say R of
T so I'll draw it a little bit
straighter than that so that's my y-axis
that is my x-axis and let's say R of T
and this is for T is less than let me
write this so this is for T is between a
and B so when T is equal to a where this
vector right here so if you actually
substitute T is equal to a here you
would get a vector a position vector
that would point to that point over
there and then as T increases it traces
out a curve or the end points of our
position vectors trace out a curve that
looks something like that
so when T is equal to B we get a
position vector that looks that points
to that point right there so this
defines a path and the path is going in
this upward direction just like that now
let's say that we have another another
position vector function let me call it
o R let me just call it I'll call it R I
don't know our reverse our sub R R or
sub R of T actually I'm just call it R
of T to make it more confusing if I try
to differentiate but it's a different
one it's the green our R of T instead of
being X of T times I it's going to be X
of a plus B minus T times I and instead
of Y of T it's going to be Y of a plus B
minus T times I and we've seen this in
the last two videos this the path
defined by these position vector by this
position vector function is going to
look more like this let me draw my axes
it's my y-axis that is my x-axis maybe I
should label them Y and X Y and X this
path is going to look just like this
instead of starting here and going there
when T is equal to 1 let me make it
clear this is also true for a is less
than or equal to T which is less than B
so T is going to go from A to B but here
when T is equal to a you substitute it
over here you're going to get this
vector you're going to get you're going
to start over here you're going to start
over there and as you increment T as you
make it larger and larger and larger
you're going to trace out that same path
but in the opposite direction so it's
the same path in the opposite direction
and so when T is equal to B you put that
in here you're actually going to get X
of a and Y of a they're right the B's
cancel out and so you're going to point
right like that so these are the same
you can imagine the shape of these paths
are the same but we're going in the
exact in the exact opposite direction so
we're going to do in this video is to
see what happens how I guess you could
say if I have some vector field let's
say I have some vector field f of XY
equals P of XY I plus Q of X Y J right
this is just a vector field over over
the Dover the XY plane how the line
integral of this vector field of this
vector field over this path over this
path compares to the line integral the
same vector field over that path how
that compares to this to we call this
the minus curve so if this is the
positive curve this is the positive
curve we're going to call this the minus
curve so how does it going over the
positive curve compared to going over
the minus curve f of F dot d R so before
I break into the math let's just think
about it a little bit let me draw this
vector field F so maybe it looks I'm
just going to draw a random stuff so you
know on every point in the XY plane it
has a vector it defines or maps a vector
to every point on the XY plane but we
really care about the points that are on
the curve so maybe the on the curve you
know this is the vector field at the
points on the curve and let me draw it
over here too so all the points on the
curve where we care about this is our
vector field
that is our vector field and let's just
get an intuition of what's going to be
going we're summing over the dot we're
taking each point along the line right
we're going to take each point along the
line and we're summing let me start over
here we're taking each point along the
line we did a different color and we're
summing the dot product of the value of
the vector field at that point the dot
product of that with dr or the
differential of our position vector
function and dr you can kind of imagine
as a small an infinitesimally small
vector going in the direction of our
movement and when we take this dot
product here it's essentially it's going
to be a scalar value but the dot product
if you remember it's the magnitude of F
in the direction of D R times the
magnitude of D R so it's this you can
imagine it's the shadow of F onto D our
let me zoom into that because I think
it's useful so this little thing that
I'm drawing right here let's say that
this is my path this is F at that point
F at that point looks something like
that and then D R at this point looks
something like that
let me do a different color dr dr looks
something like that so that is f and so
the dot product of these two says okay
let's how much of f is going in the same
direction as dr and you can kind of
imagine it as a shadow so you take the f
that's going the same direction as dr
the magnitude of that times the
magnitude of dr that is the dot product
in this case we're going to get a
positive number because this length is
positive this length is positive that's
going to be a positive number
now what if our dr was going in the
opposite direction as it is in this case
so let me draw maybe that same part of
the curve the same part of the curve we
have our F our F will look something
like that that is our F I'm drawing this
exact same part of the curve but now our
dr our dr isn't going in that direction
our dr that at this point is going to be
going in the other direction we're
tracing the curve in the opposite
direction our dr is now going to be
going in that direction so if you do so
this is
our dr so if you do f dot dr you're
taking the shadow or how much of f is
going in the direction of dr you take
the shadow down here it's going in the
opposite direction of dr so you can
imagine that when you multiply the
magnitudes you should get a negative
number our direction is now opposite
they're not going into the shadow of f
on to the same direction as dr is going
in the opposite directions dr in this
case it's going in the same direction as
dr so the intuition is is that maybe
these two things are the negative of
each other and now we can do some math
and try to see if that is definitely
definitely the case so let us first
figure out let's write an expression for
the differential dr so in this case dr
dr dt is going to be equal to X prime of
T times I plus plus y prime of T times J
in this other example in the reverse
case our dr dr dt is going to be what's
it going to be equal to it's the
derivative of x with respect to t the
derivative of this term with respect to
t that's the derivative of the inside
which is minus 1 or minus times the
derivative the outside with respect to
the inside so that's going to be it's
going to be derivative the inside is
minus 1 times the derivative of the
outside with respect to the inside x
prime of a plus B minus T times I and
then same thing for the second term
derivative of Y of this term is riveted
inside which is minus 1 times the
derivative of the outside with respect
to the inside which is Y prime of a plus
B minus T so this is going to be the
derivative of the inside times y prime
of a plus B minus T J so this is dr DT
in this case this is dr d t in that case
and then if we wanted to write the
differential dr and the forward curve
example it's going to be equal to X
prime of T times I plus y Prime
T times J times the scaler DT times the
scaler DT I could multiply it down into
each of these terms but it keeps it
simple just leaving it on the outside
same logic over here d R is equal to
minus X I change my shade of green but
it's at least it still green a plus B
minus T I minus y prime a plus B minus T
J and I'm multiplying both sides by DT
now we're ready to express this as a
function of T so this curve right here
I'll do it in pink the pink one is going
to be equal to the integral from T is
equal to a to T is equal to B of f of f
of X of f of X of T y of T dot dot this
thing over here which is I'll just write
it out here I could simplify it later X
prime of T I plus y prime of T J and
then all of that times the scalar DT
this will be a scalar value and then
we'll have another scalar value DT over
there now what is this going to be equal
to if I take this reverse integral the
reverse integral is going to be the
integral from I'm gonna need a little
more space from A to B of F of not X of
T but X of a plus B minus T y of a plus
B minus T I'm writing it small so I have
some space dot this is a vector so dot
this guy right here dot dr dot minus x
prime of a plus B minus T I minus minus
y prime of I'm using up too much space
let me scroll go back a little bit
actually let me take it make it even
simpler let me take this minus sign out
of it let me put a plus a plus and I'll
put the minus sign out front
so the minus sign is just a scalar value
so we could put that minus sign out you
know when you take a dot product and if
you multiply a scalar times a dot
product that's you could just take the
scalar out that's all I'm saying
so we can take that minus sign out to
this part right here and then you have X
prime of a plus B minus T I plus y prime
of a plus B minus T you scroll over a
little bit T J D T so this is the
forward this is when we're following it
along the forward curve this is when
we're following it along the reverse
curve now let's like we did when the
scalar example let's make a substitution
I want to make it very clear what I did
all I did here is I just took the dot
product but this negative sign I just
took it out I just said this is the same
thing as negative 1 times this thing or
negative 1 times this thing is the same
thing as that so let's make a
substitution on this side because I
really just want to show you that this
is the negative of that right there
because that's what our intuition was
going for so let me just focus on that
side so let me make a substitution U is
equal to a plus B minus T then we get D
U is equal to minus DT right just take
the derivative of both sides or you get
DT is equal to minus D U and then you
get when T is equal to when T is equal
to a U is equal to a plus B minus a so
then U is equal to B and then when T is
equal to B U is equal to a right when T
is equal to B a plus B minus B is a U is
equal to a so this thing using that
simple
that's that substitution simplifies to
this is the whole point that simplifies
to minus the integral from u is when T
is a USB from B when T is B use a the
integral from U is equal to B to use
equal to a of f of X of U X of U Y of U
- right that is you that is you dot dot
X prime of you let me write dot just
write this way X prime X prime of u
times I that's you right there plus y
prime of u times J and then instead of a
DT I need to put a D u DT is equal to
minus D u so I could write minus D u
here or just to not make it confusing
I'll put the D u here and take the minus
out front I already have a minus out
there so they cancel out they will
cancel out just like that and so you
might say hey Sal with these two things
look pretty similar to each other they
don't look like the negative each other
and I would say well you're almost right
except this guy's limits of integration
are reversed from this guy so this thing
right here if we reverse the limits of
integration we have to then make it
negative so this is equal to minus the
integral from A to B of F dot or F the
the vector f of X of U Y of U dot X
prime of U I plus y prime of U J D u and
now this is identical this integral this
definite integral is identical to that
definite integral we just have a
different variable we're doing DT here
we're having D u here but we're going to
get the same exact number for any A or B
and given this vector F and the path the
the position vector path R of T so just
to summarize everything up when you're
dealing with when you're dealing with
line integrals over vector fields the
direction matters if you go in the
reverse direction you're going to get
the negative version of that and that's
because at any point we take the dot
product you're going to get you're not
going into necessarily you're going in
the different in the opposite direction
so it'll be the negative of each other
but when you're dealing with a scalar
field we saw in the last video we
when you're dealing with the scalar
field we saw that it doesn't matter
which direction that you traverse the
path it that the positive path has the
same value as a negative path and that's
just because we're just trying to find
the area of that curtain hopefully you
found that mildly amusing